thank you
[Applause]
there's studying racist concerns while
Seattle Burns does requiring study on
racist claims means Seattle is on the
side of flames if you're hoping to
become a lieutenant in Seattle's fire
department you'd better brush up on your
social justice reading material you'll
be able to read it by the light of all
the burning buildings
according to the Washington Free Beacon
the Lieutenant's exam includes a list of
required reading assigned by the city's
HR department among them how to be an
anti-racist both sides of the fire line
A Memoir of a transgender firefighter
and a Leader's guide to unconscious bias
strangely absent from the reading list
though is the classic how to put on a
fire without burning to death
that would help
typically the written exam for the
lieutenant position includes tactical
knowledge relevant to the job like
understanding building construction
medical techniques and fire suppression
strategies and most importantly how to
make a kick-ass breakfast
but it all begs the burning question
what does wokeness have to do with
putting out fires it's the same question
many in the Seattle firefighting
Community are asking turns out the
department is over 90 percent white men
and that's a problem for the diversity
obsessed people at the Seattle
Department of Human Resources they're
even concerned that some of the
Dalmatians don't have enough black spots
[Music]
that's a weird reaction yeah it is isn't
it
those local officials including
Seattle's own fire chiefs say they want
more women and minority firefighters and
they believe the best way to do that is
by testing candidates amorphous
qualities of character rather than
tangible competencies so good luck
Seattle from now on Seattle's best will
only refer to mediocre coffee
wow
cat do you think women have been held
back from these fire fighting positions
or do you think certain types of people
become firefighters I'm not going into a
burning building
[Laughter]
and I don't think if I showed up and
like I was the person trying to get you
out people would be like
it's just so weird like what they decide
to teach you even like didn't you we all
learn like stop drop and roll like as
kids like I've not used that once I grew
up thinking I was gonna be catching on
fire like all the time you know
um but a lot of these texts I mean
people don't really realize what are in
a lot of these texts like candy for
example calls for a US Department of
anti-racism which would monitor speech
for racist content whatever that is or
isn't oh candy the author of this yes
yes to the extent that there'd just be
this massive surveillance State even
more than the one that we have now in
order to make this possible and also
like a complete destruction of the First
Amendment so I think that people say oh
yeah okay this is without realizing
maybe what they're actually saying or
maybe they do realize it and I don't I
don't know which one's worse honestly
great Point made in such an incisive
weight cat you're always looking for the
the libertarian angle and it's so true
that all of these liberal policies they
involve big government big way a Tyrus
obviously certain people are drawn to
certain professions professional
wrestling although women are there's
many women wrestlers and you're looking
at me like shalu stop talking and let me
yeah
because I'm going to be honest if I'm if
I'm in a house and it's on fire I don't
care if he's the color of a baboon's ass
just get it get me out you know what I'm
saying like this is the dumbest
I'm in the house it's burning he opens
the firefighter kicks in the door and
the heat blows the shirt off and he has
a Confederate flag tattoo on his chest
I'm not going to be like I'll wait for
someone else
exactly this is absolutely the dumb
there's a reason why white men tend to
be firefighters because they're the only
ones for some reason and we I had
friends like that in college they're the
only ones that want to investigate you
see any
it's culturally but
[Applause]
every horror movie
click sound twig breaks YouTube be like
huh let's go see what that is
that mindset
I'm gonna run into a fiery building and
get people out
you go I there needs to be more white
men doing that I'm proud of you keep it
up yes I'll make breakfast
hahaha
Dr Drew is this I mean I feel like it's
got to it's got to turn at some point
are we are we reaching critical mass
with this thing where everyone's getting
sick it's going to get ridiculous when
Cat shows up to carry somebody out to
carry tires out of the building all
right right because let me go
that's where we're headed right I'm
gonna go a little contrarian here if
they're going to have lots of trans
hires and diversity hires these people
in management positions better be
familiar with this stuff so if they're
going to be consistent all the way
across the board yeah educate yourself
and figure it out I just don't want cats
showing up to carry me out of a burning
building and when that happens there'll
be a big lawsuit and this whole thing
will turn around well that's what you're
saying is if you were advising them they
would have to learn this stuff because
they're going to get sued and they're
going to have to deal with it is that
right they're if they don't if they're
not aware of it and these are employees
that they're managing yes they can get
in trouble if they're not aware of this
stuff yeah to me
Dagan I worry that this kind of thing
the worst part of this is it's going to
drive away the people who are attracted
to these kind of jobs you know the
wokeness in the military it's gonna
young men who want to be military guys
they're like I don't want to deal with
that stuff so we're going to drive away
the very people that we're supposed to
be attracting to these jobs Seattle will
drive them away and drive them into
cities who give
um and then pyromaniacs will move to
Seattle
so let the let the fire bug that once
lived next door to me that tried to burn
my building down moved to Seattle so yay
New York gets safe
um cat is selling herself short she
might not run into the building but that
woman has a phone full of names Coast to
Coast she's got more best friends on the
planet she's got people she's going to
call to rescue out of that building I
digress
could you imagine why did you let the
school burn down I was triggered
but the goal
but these texts that Kat was talking
about the goal of the Warriors of
left-wing nuttery is to burn the system
down this is how you do it
you hire and promote people with no
knowledge of water
and I don't mean the three guys I dated
from age 18 to 22. so you yeah I mean
you think it is you think it's by design
that this is all part of it's all part
of the project help firemen firemen
it's not my pronoun not coming in
[Applause]
you're gonna get rid of the word
fireman's got to go away yeah we're
going to get rid of the word fireman
yeah no hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else